it is seven o'clock good to have you
with us this morning
it is a controversial policy that so far
is struggling to get off the ground
after several legal challenges but today
a flight taking the first asylum seekers
from the uk to rwanda is currently still
due to take off but there are reports
this morning that as few seven people
could be on that plane so at what cost
and will further legal challenges today
reduce the number of ticket holders
further still plus the uk on a fresh
collision course with the eu over
planned changes to the northern ireland
protocol lots then to talk about with
the foreign secretary who will be
sitting here shortly i'll also be joined
by ireland's minister for foreign
affairs thomas byrne as his government
calls the move
a new law it is tuesday the 14th of june
an immoral policy that shames britain
the church of england condemns the
rwanda deportations with the first
flight of asylum seekers set to leave
the uk today
two sides to every story we report from
rwanda on the accommodation awaiting the
deported i meet asylum seekers in
another camp you say they're desperate
to leave
did you think about staying in rwanda i
never i never and i will not do that and
it could be a last mistake to do so
significant concern or no big deal the
war of words over planned changes to the
northern ireland protocol that could
turn into legal action
seeking justice five years on from the
grenfell tragedy the survivors say the
wounds haven't yet healed
we are broken
we are we are
we have holes everywhere
and
it's
it's not easy what we went through what
we lived what we continue to go through
the tip of the iceberg how a thousand
people every day waiting over 12 hours
in av last year will be drilling down
into the figures
amber heart gives her first interview
since losing her rival trial against
johnny depp saying that she doesn't
blame the jury
i actually understand he's a beloved
character
and people feel they know him he's a
fantastic actor
a first look at the queen since our
platinum jubilee celebrations
also ahead on the programme
no satisfaction for rolling stones fans
as mick jagger is forced to cancel a gig
in amsterdam after testing positive for
covet
and
the falklands remembered as britain
marks the 40th anniversary we'll be
speaking to a veteran about his memories
of the conflict
[Music]
morning all an immoral policy that
shames britain condemnation this morning
from the church of england on the
government's plan to send asylum seekers
to rwanda now the first flight is due to
take off later today after a last-ditch
legal bid to halt deportations failed
but there are reports this morning there
may be as few as seven people on board
the plane very pleased to say then that
we are joined now by the foreign
secretary liz truss minister lovely to
have you this morning this morning good
morning um let us start then with rwanda
as things stand at the moment and of
course there was a significant legal
victory at the high court and the court
of appeal yesterday for the government
how many people are we expecting to send
to rwanda later today well we are
expecting to send the flight later today
i can't say exactly how many people will
be on the flight but the really
important thing is that we establish the
principle and we start to break the
model the business model of these
appalling people traffickers who are
trading in misery uh that is why we're
doing this policy and that's why it's
important that we get the flight out
today
you you might not be able to put a
specific number on it but it is it is
pretty clear that the number who will be
on that flight if anyone is on that
flight will be significantly less than
that than you had intended that's fair
to say isn't it
the important thing is that we get the
flight out we establish the principle
and we start demonstrating to people
that this business model of trafficking
people into the united kingdom risking
their lives in the english channel
simply doesn't work and it's important
we get the flight out we don't know
exactly how many people will be on that
flight but they will go on future
flights and i understand completely your
desire to avoid putting a figure on when
things may well be be fluid throughout
the day but is it possible that this
plane will take off with no one on it
there will be people on the flight and
if they're not on this flight they will
be on the next flight because we are
determined to break the model of the
appalling people traffickers and sort
this issue out which has caused untold
misery including people dying in the
english channel completely and and there
will be people watching this that that
that understand that but there will also
be people who are concerned about
the the costs of sending people to
rwanda can we put a figure on how much
today's flight will be costing
i can't put a figure on that but what we
have to look at is the cost
of
illegal immigration the cost to the
united kingdom the cost of the
individuals and their families who are
suffering from the actions of these
people traffickers that's the
that's the issue uh that we are seeking
to deal with by
putting in place this route to rwanda
and it's very important we get that
route going we show that people
trafficking doesn't work and we're able
to
reduce the costs over time of illegal
immigration into the united kingdom can
completely get that point but there are
reports this morning that suggests
because of the the the the legal action
in which you weren't successful both at
the high court there could be as few as
seven people
on that flight today
is that accurate
well as i say i don't
i don't have a figure the important
point is the principle
that we are establishing the
practicalities
going to rwanda uh if they're not on
this flight they will be on the next
flight we want to break the model of the
people trafficking you've said that
you're able to stop these costs both in
monetary costs but also in human misery
that these illegal immigration routes
are causing so you think it's value for
money no matter what it costs
it is value for money
what is the legal situation then of
people who are refused asylum in this
country popped on a plane sent to rwanda
and granted asylum there
would they be able to re-enter the
united kingdom
they will be permanently located in
rwanda and that is the agreement that we
have with the rwandan government i think
it's important to note that this is a
agreement with rwanda also about helping
rwanda develop their economy helping
people live locally in rwanda but if
they're successful in their asylum claim
in rwanda it does suggest that we might
have got it wrong at this end
but
the important thing is that we are
establishing the principle that people
are being relocated to rwanda and
settled in rwanda other people would say
that it is equally as important that as
a you know as a forward-thinking nation
we act with moral integrity and all of
this i just want to you will have seen
you'll have seen the comments of the
church of england but for you for
viewers who have not i just need to show
them this the church of england has
written a letter to say that this this
in essence shames britain could we bring
that up please alan i think we should
have it for the screen yeah
um whether or not the first deportation
flight leaves britain today for rwanda
this policy should shame us as a nation
this is the church of england saying
this it continues
i hope yeah the shame is our own because
our christian heritage should inspire us
to treat asylum seekers with compassion
fairness and justice as we have for
centuries this immoral policy shames
britain again the church of england
which as far as i'm aware is not some
den of new marxism is accusing this
government of immorality
i don't agree with that the people who
are immoral in this case are the people
traffickers trading on human misery and
that is denying that the people
traffickers are immoral they're just
simply saying that
those people neil
need to suggest an alternative policy
that will work to deal with these
illegal people trafficking explain the
logic of that to me that someone else
has to come up with a better idea than
yours for your idea to be to be ruled
out as immoral
what i'm saying is our policy
is completely legal
it's completely moral we are housing
people in a safe country in rwanda and
what i'm saying to the critics of the
policy who don't have an alternative
about how we deal with this illegal
migration is they don't have an
alternative they're criticizing our
policy which is effective and does work
when a majority a significant majority
of those passing over the channel are
successful in their asylum claims what
on earth is the rationale for this
the rationale is that we have a
migration partnership with rwanda it's
about helping develop rwanda it's about
stopping these illegal routes and people
acting
in a way that endangers human life that
is the logic of the policy let's turn
our attention to northern ireland and of
course the protocol big big discussion
ongoing you were hitting the phone
yesterday morning subcoverage and of
course across across the irish sea as
well just explain if you can in simple
terms to our viewers exactly what is
wrong with the northern ireland protocol
that your government negotiated signed
ratified
what has happened is the northern
ireland protocol and the impact of it
has undermined the belfast good friday
agreement so we're seeing people in
northern ireland not able to access the
same goods as people in great britain
we're seeing customs costs
of trading goods across the irish sea
we're seeing people not able to benefit
from the same tax breaks as people in gb
so when the chancellor at the spring
statement gave a v80 cut on solar panels
that wasn't available in northern
ireland so people in northern ireland
particularly in the unionist community
are feeling that they are less connected
to great britain and that they are not
benefiting from being part of the united
kingdom and that is a problem that we
need to deal with it has been going on
now for 18 months we've had 18 months of
negotiations we haven't got anywhere the
eu have said that they're unwilling to
change the protocol therefore we have to
act to make sure we restore
the primacy of the belfast good friday
agreement this is this is all wine in
the kind of the legal paper that you
published yesterday you set out
your use of the doctrine of necessity uh
to justify in essence going back on your
international your international
agreement with uh with the european
union just explain exactly where the
grave and immediate peril that you are
required to demonstrate to use the
doctrine
where that grave and immediate peril
exists to my mind i'm not sure that you
know having to fill in forms to send
sausages to belfast counts as grave and
immediate peril
i think we all remember
how hard won
peace and political stability of course
in northern ireland and the importance
of the belfast goodwill agreement
in establishing
both the successful north-south
relationships north-south trade and
north-south communities but also the
east-west relationships
i'd suggest that there are people who
know a lot more about the troubles than
you and i and their tech they would if
they could be sitting installment at the
moment a majority of mlas disagree with
the action that you're taking they don't
see grave in the media pedal in front of
them i'm not sure invoking the troubles
right now is helping your argument
what the belfast good friday agreement
on is based on is the principle
of parity of esteem of both communities
in northern ireland and you did mention
the mlas but those weren't mlas from the
unionist community and the point is we
need the consent
of both communities in northern ireland
we need both communities to be treated
fairly and equally and that's what we're
doing
through our northern ireland protocol
legislation i will be clear neil that we
would rather have a negotiated agreement
with the eu and this is what i said to
the eu yesterday
what we need is changes to the protocol
that are causing real problems in
northern ireland raising costs but also
making people feel
like they're not part of it have you not
negotiated with the european union
formally since february then
i have been in talks with the european
union in february in march we've had 18
months of talks
the
together
the fundamental point
is that the eu won't change the text of
the protocol and it's the text of the
protocol that's causing problems those
are again completely exactly so it's
difficult to negotiate with somebody who
won't change
the thing that you want to negotiate
with that's the consequence what
consequences in northern ireland that
you are complaining about right now were
not predicted before we ratified this
well there have been unintended
consequences and what we've seen
over time neil is things gradually
getting worse in northern ireland the
impact is what i cannot allow said the
protocol and the declarations you were
going to sign up to would involve the
checks that you now complain about that
would be highly destructive to the
northern ireland economy that you're now
complaining about all the problems that
you now identify with the northern
protocol were obvious to people on both
sides of the rbc before you signed it so
this grave and immediate peril that we
you need to have to invoke the doctrine
it's just not there you were being
warned about it three years ago
what we have seen is the situation
gradually getting worse we haven't seen
the executive in northern ireland
established since february we've seen
the trading situation get worse
diversion towards north-south away from
east-west and this is why
we need to act this is why we cannot
allow the situation to drift and we
cannot allow
the belfast good friday agreement to be
further undermined that's why the
government's determined to act and we're
doing so in a reasonable way we're not
changing the european union we're not
changing would say no to that we're not
changing the whole protocol now we're
changing the bits but the ideas that are
causing a rail
it's beyond the pale i mean in your
command paper of the middle of last year
lord frost was talking actively about
triggering article 16. indeed let's talk
about that why are we unilaterally
changing our position on the protocol
rather than using the mechanism
contained within it for precisely
moments like this
well the issue with article 16 and
triggering article 16
is all it would do
is put the situation back to what it is
now because we haven't fully implemented
the protocol we've only implemented part
of the protocol we have a standstill
arrangement at the moment and in order
to fix the problems which are generating
the issues in northern ireland the
customs
across the irish sea the requirement for
customs codes the tax differences for
the people of northern ireland from the
people of great britain we need to deal
with the protocol itself so article 16
and triggering it simply wouldn't have
delivered
the solution we need to fix the problems
in northern ireland and this is what i'm
saying to the eu
i want to negotiate with the eu but they
have to be willing to change the text of
the protocol again again you you suggest
that things are getting worse but all of
the problems that have been identified
right now in northern ireland were
identified prior to to the ratification
of the northern ireland protocol i mean
it isn't the simple truth that you all
knew
it was a bad deal when you signed up to
it but you needed to get brexit done you
got brexit done
and you intended as you are currently
doing wriggling out of it in the way
that you are
we are addressing
very very serious issues in northern
ireland that have emerged over the past
two years
honestly tell me the truth which they
have caused
problems of political instability as we
can see from the fact the executive
hasn't formed they've caused economic
and trade problems in north island just
performing the solution
the uk economy
the solution we're putting forward
doesn't make the eu any worse off
it protects the eu single market
at the same time as fixing these
problems in northern ireland so we are
working on a practical solution that
works for everybody yes we want to
persuade the eu to negotiate with us to
change the protocol to achieve that but
we cannot allow this situation in
northern ireland to drift that is where
we are now which is what i'm focused on
having responsibility for the protocol i
completely understand and what we have
you minister and it is it is away from
your brief and i understand this but it
is the anniversary of the grenfell tower
fire 72 people
lost their lives
this this government promised that
people would no longer live in unsafe
buildings like that they also promised
that people would not have to put their
hands in their pockets to rectify the
cladding neither of those things have
happened and as of this morning there
will be people waking up to this
conversation
living in unsafe buildings the likes of
grenfell tower
what is this government going to do
about it
i mean i think we all have huge sympathy
with the people caught in that appalling
tragedy and it was it was horrific i
think we all remember
how horrific it was
we have been able to
re-house i think 98 of people who are
living in grenfell i think everybody's
off been offered
alternative accommodation
we are supporting those particularly
those who live in
buildings of more than 11 stories to
make sure that they have 11 meters sorry
to make sure that they are not having to
put their hands in the pockets to pay
for cladding and i know
that my colleague the housing secretary
is doing work with the building industry
to tackle uh these these very very
serious issues of fire safety of of
building regulation but i think we just
all remember how utterly appalling
that tragedy was we certainly do um liz
trust thank you so much for joining us
really appreciate the time thank you
let's have a quick look at the papers
starting with the eye it leads with a
letter from more than 20 bishops
condemning the government's plans to
send asylum seekers to rwanda as immoral
they also say that it shames the uk
strong defense though of course from the
foreign secretary
the mail it calls it the court calls it
the court of common sense presumably
referring to the court withdrawal and
the high court there
are threats from the eu to take legal
action over the government's plans to
rewrite parts of the northern ireland
post-brexit trade protocol on the front
of the ft not entirely surprisingly
and here's the mirror it says that
prince william threatened to pull out of
an event making former pm tony blair a
knight of the garter if that is
prince andrew was allowed to take part
well we have some pictures coming to as
i believe uh from
dover live pictures at the moment but of
course as we were hearing from the
foreign secretary the desire is uh to
bring to an end at the trade of the
people smugglers how many people have
lost their lives
trying to cross the channel
well the first asylum seekers are
expected to be deported to rwanda later
as we were saying in our interview with
ms truss and the country is already a
destination for other asylum seekers
from the capital kigali shingi marariki
has this
report rwanda is ready
50 rooms are waiting for the first
asylum seekers to arrive from the uk
we have a
twin room meaning that each room has a
capacitor accommodating to a person
the manager wants them to feel at home
he's tried to think of everything they
might need
the signs are in english and arabic
there's a prayer room
two computer centers and a gift shop we
have some uh different things like
clothes and cigarettes as as you know
they like a cigarette yes
this is their home table they will live
in good condition
the asylum seekers are free to leave any
time
this isn't a detention center it's their
first home in rwanda
paid for by the uk government in a deal
worth 120 million pounds for rwanda it
has to start at some point so this is
the beginning and you know more about
the cost per refugee
in this scheme
um it'll be about
about the same
that the uk spends on
on accommodating and processing migrants
this scheme isn't actually saving money
these are people so they have to be
accommodated in and safe dignified
facilities and
that this investment ensures that they
that they get treated with respect
[Applause]
rwanda already hosts asylum seekers the
people coming from the uk will not be
the first
[Music]
40 miles away from the capital off the
beaten track is this safe haven a
temporary home for people the un refugee
agency have brought here from libya
refugees who have taken dangerous
journeys trying to get to europe the
refugees here have similar experiences
to the ones coming from the uk but
there's a big difference ones here are
hoping for resettlement in places like
canada or sweden the ones coming from
the uk have a one-way ticket rwanda is
their final destination
peter fled war in south sudan and
torture at the hands of people smugglers
the un have found him a new home in
finland
it is our last hope that we should be in
a free world one day if i would be
prepared to stay here wonder i better go
back to libya did you think about
staying in rwanda i never i never and i
will not do that and it would be a last
mistake to do so
more than a thousand people have come
through this transit camp in the last
three years
they have three choices resettling in
another country returning home or
staying in rwanda
so far no one has chosen rwanda
the asylum seekers arriving here will
feel the same
thrust into a new country with no choice
but people here are confident that
rwanda is a place they will call home
a place where they can build a future
shinki marike sky news kigali
a bit of breaking economic news for you
at the moment the ons june labour market
stats are out uh let's bring in sky's
paul kelsey who joins us
with some analysis and all of this okay
paul what have we been hearing and good
news bad news for us all
it is it's a mixture let's start with
the good news shall we these are the
figures for the labor market in the uk
for it's a mixture of uh numbers for
april numbers for may the bit people
will want to hear is that unemployment
is down again just 3.8
close to a 50-year low something we hear
ministers hailing all the time but we
have to set that against the fact that
still fewer people in employment than
there was before the pandemic and in
fact more than 20
of people are what's cost is
economically inactive that they're not
in work and they're not looking for work
and that helps explain the other side of
the coin here which is that 1.3 million
vacancies exist in the economy it's a
record number of jobs roles that are
unfilled at companies and explains why
sector after sector is complaining that
they simply cannot fill the jobs they
need we've heard tourism airlines
complain of this the agriculture
industry now the latest this morning bt
say it's slowing down broadband rollout
because many of these companies touching
on brexit which you just discussed can't
easily turn to the european union to
fill jobs that are not being filled
domestically
on top of all of that pay in real terms
because of the high inflation rates we
have has fallen another 2.2
so you are earning less in real terms
despite the fact you might be working
quite hard this all comes after
yesterday's figures of another
contraction in the economy in april 0.3
down gdp if you can't fill jobs you
can't grow as a company you can't start
to deliver the economic growth to the
country so badly needs to try and pull
away from the current malaise
paul many thanks indeed
uh some of the day's other news now and
all bridges to the ukrainian city of
severo donetsk are now impassable as
russian forces established control over
most of the area
the mayor of the eastern luhans region
said it's now impossible to evacuate
civilians from the city or to get
humanitarian aid in
first minister nicolas sturgeon will
today launch the first in a new series
of documents
making the case for scottish
independence the snp leader has
repeatedly said she wants a referendum
before the end of next year despite
strong opposition from the uk government
a former spokesman for donald trump has
said that one of the president's most
influential advisers rudy giuliani was
drunk on election night when he advised
him to prematurely declare victory the
allegations were made in evidence to the
congressional committee investigating
the january 6th capital riot they also
heard from the former u.s attorney
general bill barr who accused president
trump of being detached from reality
over allegations of voter fraud
i was
somewhat demoralized because i thought
boy if he really believes this stuff he
has you know
lost contact with
with uh
he's become detached from reality if he
really believes this stuff my opinion
then and my opinion now
is that uh
the election was not stolen by fraud
and
i haven't seen anything since the
election that changes my mind on that
a woman who wrote an online essay called
how to murder your husband
has been sentenced to life in prison for
murdering her husband
seventy-one-year-old nancy crampton
brophy was initially convicted of murder
last month but her essay was not allowed
to be used as evidence in the trial
police in brazil say that search teams
looking for a british journalist and his
colleague who disappeared in the amazon
more than a week ago are still looking
for their bodies they contradicted
reports yesterday that dom phillips and
his colleague bruno pereira had been
found dead
the upcoming buzz lightyear film will
not be shown in 14 countries in
14 countries in the middle east and asia
saudi arabia and the united arab
emirates are among the countries to ban
the movie because it features characters
in a same-sex relationship
sharing a kiss
it's frustrating i mean we've dealt with
that with marvel and uh you know it
feels good to be a part of something
that is making social progress but it's
uh it's with this ribbon of bittersweet
frustration that at the same time there
are still places that have not caught up
the queen has been photographed for the
first time since her platinum jubilee
celebrations uh this was at the order of
the garter ceremony where the former
prime minister tony blair received his
night
notably missing however was prince
andrew who stepped down from royal
duties in 2019.
now beijing is rushing to contain a
coveted 19 outbreak traced to a 24-hour
bar with millions facing testing and
thousands under targeted lockdowns uh
someone who knows a thing or two about
this our asia correspondent tom cheshire
joins us from the chinese capital quick
uh look on your social media this
morning tom i mean you've been falling
full of some of these covered
regulations as well tell us what
happened to you
morning neil yeah i mean it's really
groundhog day uh in china with zero
covered policy and what's really
affecting everyone right now is the
uncertainty so this morning
i went to the gym before work and as i
left the gym i was told i couldn't leave
the gym they blocked the fire exits they
said we had to stay until afternoon it
took a bit of negotiation but we got out
uh india and other people had to say i'm
not entirely sure why it's left out it's
quite a lucky escape other people my
colleague leo the asia producer he was
kept in his flat for uh 24 hours while
there was a positive covert case in his
building before eventually being left
out but lots of other people aren't so
lucky they've just been put away in
their compounds or they're taken away to
quarantine as part of this zero covered
push it has been going on a while
there's been an outbreak here since
april we're in a lockdown basically a
five-week lockdown where all restaurants
were shot schools were shut parks were
shut everyone was basically told to stay
and work at home and they lifted those
restrictions just last week what
happened was one person came here to
sanleton this is a shopping and
nightlife area in beijing he had a
pretty spectacular three days we visited
about a dozen two dozen uh restaurants
uh clubs and bars led to a huge super
spreading event more than 200 cases now
all these bars have now been shut down
all the restaurants are take away only
people asking how long will these
measures last because right now it
doesn't feel like there's any sort of
exit plan the plan really is just to
stick with zero covered
tom many thanks indeed
at night five years on from the grenfell
tower fire
there will be a service at westminster
abbey and survivors campaigners and
brief families will take part in a
silent walk to remember the 72 people
who died last night the tower was lit up
angry to mark the date charlotte lost
reports
72 lives lost 72 families destroyed
72 reasons to make sure another tragedy
like grenfell cannot happen again
it's been five years since the fire but
for the bereaved and survivors that time
has stood still
the pain in this community is everywhere
it's still written on the walls on the
railings on the faces of those trying to
fight on
hanan wahhabi survived the fire that
night her brother abdul aziz and his
family did not
you can see the impact obviously they
have cleaned it
my brother was wearing this when he died
uh
so i have this in my bedroom
you keep it next to you yeah yeah
hernan has little left from her flat or
her brothers just memories they were a
loving family
there was a lot of laughter a lot of
joking
a lot of dry humor in that household
there was
after the fire hernan and her two
children were left to live in one hotel
room for 18 months
she now has somewhere to live but she
doesn't call it home
grenfell was my home
and i still see that as my home
i mean there are times when
i might be driving
and i forget
that grenfell happened and
it's like committed to other days and
i'm driving towards the tower
and then i'm like oh my god where are
you going you don't live there anymore
as the years have gone on rather than
starting to heal many people here have
told me that their trauma is getting
worse that they feel weaker and more
exhausted with a continued fight for
answers and for justice
and it's a fight that's left its mark
yes
we smile we may laugh we may joke
but the only way we do that is to whack
on plasters in every single hole that we
have we have wounds our wounds are
massive
we cover them
but we can only cover them for
just for a brief period and then
literally when those doors close you
don't see us we are broken
we all know how the grenfell fire
started what's unclear is how this will
all end the ongoing public inquiry has
revealed a catalogue of failures yet not
one person has been charged with a crime
and it's this absence of accountability
that five years on is still at the heart
of the trauma here charlotte lomas sky
news
time now for the weather
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
temperatures expected to sort into the
30s and some parts of england this week
certainly and for a mostly fine few days
although there will be outbreaks of rain
in the northwest and it will be turning
warmer mostly fine right now although
chilly out of time in the south northern
scotland largely overcast with patchy
rain
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
uh now regular viewers will know that i
love a bit of looking up at the sky but
stargazers are in for a treat this week
june's picturesque full moon will
illuminate the sky
known as the strawberry moon it comes
ahead of the summer solstice and is the
first of two consecutive super moons
this year at the strawberry moon named
as such to mark the ripening of june
bearing strawberries that could be
gathered by north american tribes i am
reliably informed
another story truly ain't no
satisfaction for rolling stones fans in
amsterdam after mick jagger
tested positive for coving
[Music]
could do with putting a jumper on
couldn't they i mean they had to cancel
their show in amsterdam scheduled for
last night the uk managed to get a look
in though the band played in liverpool
last week still going strong
coming up next i'll be speaking to
ireland's minister for european affairs
after the uk moved to override parts of
the northern ireland protocol that's
next
[Music]
welcome back the european union has
threatened to take legal action over the
government's plans to rewrite parts of
the northern ireland protocol the prime
minister says the changes were legal and
necessary to secure the future of the uk
while insisting that any talk of tariffs
would be a gross overreaction
let's speak now to ireland's minister
for european affairs thomas bernie joins
us now mr burn great to have you on the
program this morning um
i wonder if you can just respond
directly then to the justification
provided by the prime minister yesterday
and indeed the foreign secretary today
the the the good friday agreement is at
risk if we don't sort out the issues
with the protocol and this is the only
way to do it
well we don't accept that at all because
the good friday agreement is an
international agreement again there's
two sides to it so it's not possible for
one side to make a decision unilaterally
it's exactly the same with the protocol
ireland and the united kingdom they're
called guarantors of that good fight
agreement if there are problems or where
there are issues and that god knows
about many over the years both
governments work together to resolve
them that's the opposite approach now
has been adopted by the british
government in relation to the protocol
and i think using the good friday women
to justify that is another example of
unilateralism which is completely
inappropriate in northern ireland
i mean you you've gone quite far in
saying that actually what we saw
yesterday was an attempt by the
government to legitimize breaking the
law just explain that point
well i absolutely stand by that because
when you have an agreement between
countries you're expected the country is
expected to comply with the agreement
not to break it
and that is breaking the law of breaking
international law i think we have to be
very very clear on that i think the
reputational damage for britain well of
course that's the matter for britain
itself but there's no doubt and that it
is astonishing many people
around the world that britain would sign
a treaty and then decide not to comply
with it and this is particularly the
case when there has been a stream of
negotiation there
papers produced by the european
commission to try to resolve uh some of
the issues under the protocol but the
idea that you just walk away from your
treaty obligations i think is a really
unprecedented and it's not just that
britain has done this but i have no
doubt
that other countries which may not be as
committed to democracy and the rule of
law is britain are now looking at what
britain has done and maybe they
reconsider treaty obligations why
shouldn't they britain
does this if britain breaks the law i
think that it is a bad move it's a bad
move britain but it's a very bad move uh
for northern ireland in particular the
protocol is operating basically the way
the british government said it would in
all the documentation published at the
time and science so nothing it can say
now could be considered to be a surprise
or unexpected it's operating exactly
in the way to protect the island of
ireland to make sure there's no hard
border there and that's what we all said
that we wanted at that time that's what
britain said i think it's an incumbent
britain to work with the european union
to resolve some of those issues and
those issues are only part of the story
of the protocol the other bigger part of
the story of the protocol is that the
northern ireland economy is doing really
really well agriculture entirely depends
on the protocol manufacturing and
exporting are benefiting hugely from the
protocol those are parts of which which
certainly have a bigger burden now
that's exactly what the european union
has been looking at to try to resolve
and make the burden less for them that's
important of brexit and that the
protocol was there and to try to help
okay minister i don't expect you to
fully know the mind of the prime
minister given what you have said given
that all of these issues these problems
as identified by the british government
were predicted before they ratified the
treaty why on earth in your mind did
they sign up to it in the first place
well they were predicted let's be clear
by the british covenant in their own
documentation and as to how it would
work i don't know i can't read the mind
of the prime minister and but it does
seem to us that there's a certain
attempt to appease certain people uh
within the tory party in relation to
northern ireland i have no doubt that if
we come to a good solution the parties
will follow the lead of the governments
we already saw that where at the start
of last year the dup themselves were
talking about using the protocol to the
advantage of northern ireland they
weren't overly happy with it but they're
saying yes we can work with this and
there is certainly a benefit to that the
benefit is undeniable i think if we try
to pull back from the protocol as the
british government are trying to do uh
you will not only destroy that benefit
but it will lead northern ireland to
greater instability the good value
agreement requires both governments to
work together and i urge the british
government to reconsider this dangerous
course of action and to work with the
european union on protocol management to
work closely with us and the irish
government uh on northern ireland
matters and the hand of friendship is
extended from dublin
sure but what that what then is the
solution indeed is there a solution is
there a way that we can we can we can
square this circle that doesn't involve
there being some kind of border down the
irish sea or a hard border between the
republic and northern ireland
but there's not a hard border between
the
party i understand that i understand
there is no reason but
is there a solution that doesn't involve
one of those two options
well
the protocol is the solution to the
difficulty that people said was faced by
their by the island of ireland that is
the unique scenario here there are some
checks from britain to northern ireland
there are no checks in northern ireland
britain and that then allows northern
ireland to benefit from the best of both
worlds and that's i thought what we all
wanted but there is let me be very clear
britain will be held to its
international obligations let there be
no doubt about that and this will be
worked through the legal obligation will
stay no matter what the house of commons
does no matter what the government
proposes and i think the better option
then for the british government at the
moment is to talk to the european union
on the basis of what we propose and what
the european union has proposed in terms
of easing the burden comes directly from
having spoken to unionists having spoken
to business having spoken to farmers and
of course business let's be clear by and
large supports the protocol of course
they want some of the uh burdens eased
that's the european union once as well
but they support the protocol because
they see the benefits of it
thomas burn great to have you on the
programme this morning thanks for
joining us
thank you thank you
let's bring in our political
correspondent ali forte you have had a
busy morning much like me what have you
made of what's been going on i mean
clearly a couple of things to talk about
but northern ireland protocol let's
start there yeah and i think um it was
really interesting to hear what liz
trust had to say because of course she
is a person in government that is has
been involved in negotiating this and um
yesterday the government invoked
something called the doctrine of
necessity that means they basically need
to show that there is immediate serious
grave peril um and i think there are
people that are saying if that is the
case why would they firstly not invoke
article 16 which is sort of the
emergency call that you can pull to
immediately um unilaterally change um
the northern ireland protocol and to
suspend it but clearly that hasn't
happened and she said um that she is
addressing serious issues emerged over
the last two years i think the question
is why didn't they expect these issues
much earlier on yeah i think that's a
very fair point to me ali we will see
you next hour and indeed and then
o'clock for your take on uh everything
but for now thank you
now over a thousand people every day
waited over 12 hours in a early in
england in 2021 according to a new
report
the vice president of the royal college
of emergency medicine dr adrian broyle
joins us on the program dr ball very
good morning to you
do give us an idea of of what the
research has found here and the figures
are pretty stark aren't they 12-hour
weights in accident in emergency i mean
it's not tolerable in the long term
no so we found that far too many people
are waiting too long the reason we've
done this report is the way that we
measure
12-hour stays in england um relies on
something called a decision to admit and
this is
something that's made a couple of hours
maybe several hours after a patient's
been in an emergency departments and the
problem is that measure gets gained so
we've gone um back and said actually
what's the time somebody arrives in a
department to what time and they
register as a patient and how long many
of those patients are staying 12 hours
because actually we think that's
actually what matters to patients and we
found that the figure it's 14 times as
big as the official figures
i mean this means people are waiting too
long um and that's having
really really long stays in emergency
plans now a long stay in the um when you
go to an airport because your flight is
cancelled is tedious and annoying
when you've got patients who are sick
who are waiting to be admitted into
hospital beds this is a serious safety
concern
so can we can we generalize at all dr
ball about about the reasons behind this
clearly covert
has placed an awful strain on on the
health service in general but when we're
talking you know 14 times as high as the
government figures 12 hour weights left
right and center it suggests to me that
it's a broader problem than the pandemic
yeah and you could be right these
weren't a problem in 2015
and the number has been steadily growing
up but over this year we seem to agree
i've got to a tipping point where the
number of 12-hour stays has just um
well the number of 12-hour days we've
had so far this year is actually greater
than the number of 12-hour stairs we've
had in the last five years
the reasons for this the pandemic has
accelerated this a bit but actually
there's a whole bunch of other factors
we don't have enough beds um we
within our main hospitals the beds that
we've got are being used by too many
people waiting to be discharged either
to home because of the difficult
interface between acute hospitals and
social care
it's a big complicated problem but i
have been here before i was qualified in
the early 90s and i remember similar
weights where we had enormous long
waiting emergency care really wasn't
very good
and it was turned around it took a lot
of political will commitment to
investment but it is fixable
just in terms of the the figures and
access to this data how easy was it for
you to compile it
so this data is collected routinely but
not published and that's an important
point we think that this data should be
published it should be in the public
domain and published alongside all the
other the performance metrics that the
nhs publishes
i think there'll be plenty of people who
agree uh dr adrian ball great to have
you on the program
thank you thank you
now the actor amber hertz has given her
first tv interview since losing her
libel case against her ex-husband johnny
depp
she says she doesn't blame the jury for
not believing her
i don't care what one thinks about me
or what judgments you want to make about
what happened in the privacy of my own
home and my marriage behind closed doors
i don't presume the average person
should know those things and so i don't
take it personally but even somebody who
is
sure
i'm deserving
of
all this hate in vitriol
even if you think
that i'm lying you still couldn't look
me in the eye and tell me that you think
on social media there's been a fair
representation you cannot tell me
that you think that this has been fair
there's no polite way to say it the jury
looked at the evidence you presented
they listened to your testimony and they
did not believe you
they thought you were lying
how could
i put it this way
how could they
make a judgment how could they not come
to that conclusion they had sat
in those seats
and heard through over three weeks
of non-stop relentless testimony
from paid
employees
and towards the end of the trial randos
as i say
so you don't blame the jury i don't
blame them it wasn't i i don't blame
them i actually understand he's a
beloved character
and people feel they know him he's a
fantastic actor their job is to not be
dazzled by that
their job is to look at the facts and
the evidence
and they did not believe
your testimony or your evidence
i
again
how could they after listening to three
and a half weeks of testimony
about how i was
a non-credible person
not to believe a word that came out of
my mouth
now the price of bitcoin plummeted to 10
to below 25 000 yesterday for the first
time since december 2020. the move uh
well it dragged other cryptocurrencies
into the red with their total value
falling below one trillion dollars for
the first time since january last year
soaring u.s inflation has prompted some
investors to ditch riskier assets like
cryptocurrencies
let's bring in the technology
journalists will guide to explain
what on earth is going on in a world
that i don't particularly understand
very well well always good to see you
let's start with a definitional issue
just explain exactly what bitcoin is
crypto currencies are
yeah crypto currencies are digital
currencies they're not governed by a
bank somebody can't step in to control
the level of inflation those kind of
things so they're not regulated in the
way we would consider uh traditional
finance and traditional money and that's
by large where i think this whole
problem has come from and i'm sure
you're going to get tons of
cryptocurrency fans uh tweeting you and
telling you that i've misinterpreted
this completely but this feels very much
like the gold rush it feels like we're
all going we've all rushed into a town
some of us have started making some
money from it a couple of us have opened
banks
they'll be like me opening the bank of
will gaia and what's happened here is
some of these organizations that have
gone into trading crypto currencies now
there's been this massive correction
i've also had problems we've had an
organization called celsius which
offered cryptocurrency loans to people
they've ceased they've currently put us
suspended on all their trading and as a
result of that the whole cryptocurrency
market yesterday lost about another 10
to 15 percent it's it's sort of crazy
times in this world where it's like on
being on a roller coaster i know the
markets are all volatile but you could
be you really have to hold your nerve if
you've got something like cryptocurrency
because it can flood these
cryptocurrencies they can fluctuate by
20 to 30 in a day on a bad day
but but but you mentioned celsius there
and celsius and others
operate as if they are banks but they
don't aren't regulated in the same way
that banks are which is why you know you
went on social media yesterday after the
celsius announcement there were
thousands of people complaining that
they had millions tens of millions of
pounds tried tied up in crypto that they
couldn't get their hands on
yeah now this is the problem it goes
back to the bank of world guy at
principle um it's all right when the
times are good but if you're not
regulated by the financial standards
authority or the u.s equivalent or any
kind of global equivalent you can then
shut doors and do what you fancy there
was a period yesterday where binance
which is world's biggest cryptocurrency
exchange had to temporarily suspend uh
trading of uh their their cryptocurrency
because of a technical issue and um that
was something that was was quickly
resolved but you find in these
situations that without the financial
standards authority and others involved
there is this danger of volatility and
really big fans of cryptocurrency say
that these organizations shouldn't be
part of it but if you're an everyday
investor if you're somebody at home who
genuinely believes the ads that you can
see online which says you can get 18
return or something like that right now
that's very appealing to people and
because this isn't regulated it's those
people that are piling in with money
they really don't have they're the ones
who are being most impacted by this
whole volatility and cryptocurrency
everybody thought it was going that way
we're obviously seeing a massive
correction right now i mean bitcoin i
mean if you invested in bitcoin in the
early days i mean you'd be sitting
pretty right now but but it is true to
say isn't it there are quite a few bad
faith actors operating in the
cryptocurrency world or you know any
number of people coming out with their
own crypto currency which you know what
a surprise collapses six months later
yeah it's true and i was uh fortunate in
that i ended up buying um nearly two
bitcoin in 2012 when i was trying to do
something for a radio interview i didn't
understand it at all at the time and i
purchased them i still have them sat
somewhere but i'm not relying on it it's
just sat there as a glorious experiment
for me and possibly the only time in my
life that taking a financial punt has
ever worked um but
for some people who literally would pump
their savings in let's say it's a young
person who's trying to get a deposit for
a house they put this sort of percentage
of money in because they think it's
going to grow over six months or a year
they've lost it and
that's the
the crazy situation at the moment we've
got
i'm so sorry i'm gonna have to let you
get back to the tech shed because i've
got 15 seconds left on the program love
that place i'll see you there one day
soon uh that's a lot for the seven
o'clock car stay right where you are